alors bon soir à la planète
c'est une explosion de joie qui
accompagne ce départ de tam-tam canada
en direct de montréal
il est 11 heures 11 minutes nous tenons
parole presque à chaque semaine sont
toujours là alors vous vous n'êtes pas
mais c'est pas votre faute
alors bienvenue un ce facebook live sur
youtube live et ce rci la sève jauge
oublie certainement des plateformes y en
a certainement certaines qui nous qui
nous exploitent comme des travailleurs
quelque part dans des pays où même sur
d'autres planètes fils alors autour de
la table de cette émission du canada
nous avons nos collègues habituels on
est on salue la caméra 38 comme
d'habitude et oui au plan d'ensemble qui
fait du non open en plein dans
l'ensemble c'est pour le même prix
bonjour à toute la planète
bonjour en effet alors ses tours de
passe passe de caméras on les doit à ces
deux personnes qui sont ici à la droite
du juge
il y a léo gimeno de la section de
latino show il ya marie claude simard
bonjour marie claude la section
tellement ce sont des webmestres sont
les titres officiels et des poids lourds
ici de la communication journalisme et
sierre si nous avons ismaël tourisme un
jour et puis alice bonjour a dit
stéphane et moi mon team et merci de
m'avoir nommé si tous ces gens sur la
planète
c'est chouette comme ces trains comme
non démission mais c'est pas le bon ton
mais c'est quand même l'intention qui
compte
vous connaissez la tradition parce que
vous êtes des des vieux routiers
1 comment comment cette émission par la
découverte du sujet comment on fait ça
le cinquième match on se prononce en
jean
vous êtes prêts à long terme tout le
monde à la maison joue également et dans
le camion
on regarde quel est le sujet cette
semaine ne sautait pas aux conclusions
mais dès que vous pensez que vous avez
une piste vous le dit
le cannabis peut-être peut-être la
légalisation penser cette attention ne
sautez pas aux conclusions ces bleus
donc en vigueur la liberté là c'est bien
ça c'est le canada c'est la liberté mais
beaucoup de couleurs dans notre thème
aujourd'hui des couleurs d'automne oui
oui
mais ça c'est le cannabis mais ça c'est
du cannabis effective égalisation
officielle et va te regarder la magie
par la magie de l'image apparaît la
feuille de cannabis
maintenant la feuille d'érable sur le
drapeau officiel
c'est comme ça vicieuse ma config et
même dans l'hymne nations co les annabis
oh mon dieu je n'avais pas entendu cela
quel autre histoire amusante elle joue
entendu cette semaine parce que ça fait
le tour du monde mais beaucoup de
détails peut-être que les gens à
l'étranger n'ont pas eu vingt premières
journées il ya déjà
il manque déjà du cannabis dans les
locaux pour vendre ça c'est spécial la
plupart la personne de vente et de la
pénurie
oui 6 mais on est on sent pas encore
l'odeur dans les rues parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de vin il faisait un peu froid
je pense et mercredi faisaient quoi 0
dessus des grilles extérieures mais
c'est incroyable un mois ce qui m'a
impressionné c'est vraiment la file
indienne les différents points devant
vous est passé devant j'ai regardé les
images à la télévision c'était vraiment
quelque chose d'étonnant reçu reproche
déjà vu aussi les blés pamiers à la
première contravention
un passant qui conduit c'est sur les
faits il s'est affaibli ses seins
quelques dollars 66 à 72 600 $ et de
l'autre côté on pardonne ce qui avait un
casier judiciaire c'est fait c'est
officiel c'est une volonté du
gouvernement de volonté quand les
volontés et puis il y aura des élections
il se trouve que l'opposition demande au
gouvernement trudeau d'annuler
totalement le casier pour les personnes
ça fait combien de millions de personnes
ce qui est grave et moins quand c'est ça
les valait pas des super g super con
semaine d'accord mais il ya une pénurie
mais on peut toujours se tourner encore
vers le marché noir c'est de consolation
si ce matin il y avait eu aussi des
dépôts question des sont déjà en train
de poursuivre les gens qui vivent
illégalement
ah oui ça continue est vite fait il
paraît que les prix sont plus
intéressants du côté du marché de moi
c'est moins élevés que les prix du des
gouvernements passés sont les
gouvernements provinciaux qui fait que
les prix et on a beaucoup de choses à
faire ensemble aujourd'hui je voulais
connaître tu peux vous histoire de fori
puis parler de l'histoire un peu plus
sérieux de préoccupation que beaucoup
d'autres canadiens ont comme moi par
rapport à ces questions de
alors voilà j'ai dit mon opinion c'est à
dire je tenais vous parlez de ça cette
semaine parce que c'est très important
dans la psyché de 2,2 ce pays en ce
moment c'est mark 1 je voulais montrer
j'ai vu plein d'affaires moi cette
semaine comme vous j'ai vu quelque chose
qui est une image si vous voulez une
vidéo je préparais ça ça s'appelle un
pacte l'impact s'est selon statistique
canada les prévisions à l'épaule
précision métrologique mais les
prévisions de consommation
ça va faire ça au canada qu il va avoir
une explosion de nouveaux consommateurs
regardez l'image on est 4 4 millions de
consommateurs sur les populations 37
millions actuellement
il va avoir selon statistique canada la
vie pratiquement le double 61% c'est
plus que le double devrait avoir 7,1
millions de consommateurs jeu pas d'ici
combien tu as à d'ici 2000 quelque chose
d'autre je pensais pas l'an dernier
et puis d'autres sympathiquement le
double presque de 4.5 millions en 7.1
millions
je connais des gens qui en ont pas
acheter parce qu'il voulait pas parce
que c'était légal
mais s'ils ont la possibilité de les
faire légalement ça va ça mais il y en a
qui ont dit haut et fort leur volonté de
continuer à acheter dans le marché noir
à s'approvisionner dans le marché noir
est étant donné qu'il n'y a pas de
schille ya pas de files d'attentes ça va
très très vite et puis les prix sont
qu'elle hérissons sont intéressants
puisque vous parlez n'ont pas cédé au
premier jeu de la grosse boule de
l'émission à musique les rares il ya
trois jeunes mission occasion de
remporter des pas des prix de
participation mais des points de
félicitations 20 points pour ce premier
jeu c'est un peu s'en trouvait pas dans
une salle du cinéma
les lumières j'ai fait ça tourne à
l'érotisme
mais l autisme cannabis et robin
démission et tu te fous risa on va
peut-être fini plus tard les premiers
jeux 20 points d'accord tam tam canada
c'est très sérieux et enquêter dans les
10 provinces canadiennes pour savoir où
se vend en ce moment le gramme de
cannabis de moins cher alors on a fait
naître que dans 4 des talismans se
promener et nous allons trouver la
réponse dans quelle province astro maman
vous donner la réponse je vais vous
révéler je voudrais savoir - si on fait
la moyenne des prix dans différentes
provinces telles qu'établies par les
gouvernements provinciaux quel est le
prix moyen d'un gramme de cannabis au
canada
quand on voit magasin maintenant combien
ça va coûter crime et moyennes moi
j'arrête 12 dollars nous avons cinq et
cinquante cinq et cinquante une grosse
barre de chocolat quoi très grosse pas
convaincant bien est ce que vous savez
combien des cigarettes on peut faire
avec une grand jeu kingdom et le
cigarette de tabac au disque et au nom
dé cannabis et d'en douter le moins
possible peut-être trois d'olhain cinq
ans je crois de l'ancien casas et de
marché noir ce qu'il put prendre la
bonne réponse sans vous we dare 10
félicitations franchement experts s'est
dévoilée par la même occasion
j'aime pas ça moi quand j'étais jeune on
achetait pour eux je bouge pas moi j'en
achetais pas les actes je pense que tu
aimais dollars pour 10 g ça fait
longtemps que ça mais c'était au marché
noir mois
voilà mille bas prix mais quand j'avais
14 ans je savais pas que la drogue a
existé
à 14 ans j'ai dit à mon fils et moi j'en
ai jamais vu non de toute ma vie à la
télé mais dans la vraie vie
jamais c'est l'euphorie mais avait quand
même des questions sérieuses très légal
rattache à tous à vous en avait parlé
bon on va maintenant aborder la question
avec une experte qui est un peu assis
entre deux sièges selon moi elle est
experte dans le domaine pénal est aussi
experte dans le domaine des droits
civils civils
alors voici marie-ève sylvestre et puis
bonjour madame si vous travaillez à
l'université d'ottawa jeudi que vous
êtes assis entre deux sièges c'est
amusant c'est rigolo mais en fait les
canadiens eux sont au ps si présentement
le point de vue légal entre deux sièges
malgré la légalisation
oui absolument parce que bon on parle
décriminalisation du cannabis mais ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
c'est une décriminalisation partiel
seulement
donc il ya par exemple la possession de
cannabis achetés légalement donkey
décriminaliser les adultes peuvent avoir
sur leur personne dans les espaces
publics jusqu'à 30 grammes de cannabis
séchées peuvent en accumuler autant
qu'ils veulent à la maison mais
évidemment leurs outils et des bémols
puisque dans certaines provinces par
exemple que des limites
les jeunes par ailleurs de moins de 18
ans ne peuvent pas acheter de cannabis
est toujours d'ailleurs criminel un acte
criminel de leur en vendre puis on peut
pas non plus posséder plus de 30 grammes
de cannabis dans les espaces du blé qui
donc il ya encore un très grand nombre
de restrictions là haut niveau
de la procession de la vente et de la
régulation quand vous dites les jeunes
faudra être précis
c est ce que ces 18 ans ou 21 à ce que
ce 19 août ouais ouais en fait
exactement donc la loi fédérale prévoit
que le jeune de moins de 18 ans ne peut
pas être criminalisé pour posséder
jusqu'à cinq grammes de cannabis dans
les espaces publics par contre les
provinces ont un marge de manoeuvre pour
augmenter cette limite d'âge l'a donc
par exemple en ontario on sait que la
limite d'âge et à 19 ans au québec
présentement elle est à 18 ans mais le
nouveau gouvernement élu a indiqué son
intention d'augmenter la limite d'âge à
21 ans donc il faut surveiller sa d'une
province à l'autre il ya des variations
le 21 ainsi sa 2ème cas au québec moi je
pense aux vendeurs en ontario que ce
soit le marché loin où le marché enfin
ils ont le marché public 18 ans en
ontario
est ce qu'il y aurait des jeunes qui
prendrait le tout comme ça le samedi
soir pour aller acheter quelque chose de
l'autre côté de la frontière
m absolument c'est déjà le cas
d'ailleurs pour l'alcool alors en
ontario ses 19 ans au québec ses 18 ans
donc c'est clair qu'il ya du trafic
inter provinciale surtout dans les
régions frontières comme la mienne moi
j'habite à voir gatineau donc c'est
clair que les jeunes vont aller là où
ils peuvent se procurer effectivement la
substance la plus vive adam sylvestre
est ce qu'il existe des dispositions
légales pour contrôler ce trafic là du
côté des jeunes sur internet parce qu'il
y en a qui développe toutes sortes de
stratagèmes pour pouvoir se ravitailler
en ligne oui bah alors qu'il faut savoir
présentement justement c'est que par
exemple en ontario le seul la seule
façon d'acheter du cannabis licite
depuis le 7 octobre c'est de le
commander en ligne donc pas encore de
magasins qui ont été ouvertes avec
pignon sur rue alors c'est c'est le cas
au québec par ailleurs il ya un certain
nombre de boutiques qui a déjà qui ont
déjà été ouverts et part pour ce qui est
du commerce en ligne d'abord il faut
s'identifier faut indiquer notre âge au
moment de la commande
puis au moment de la ligue
postes canada va effectuer des
vérifications quant à l'âge donc que
c'est la personne qui a commandé qui va
recevoir la commande puis elle devra
montrer une pièce d'identité au post il
a bon d'accord ça a l'air assez logique
comme système est là il y avait pas d
histoire de faux sites internet
gouvernementaux en ligne cette semaine
dix ans ou et envoyer notre de l'argent
avec l'argent on va vous envoyer le
reste ben là c'est sûr qu'il va falloir
être très prudent là pour justement
vérifier ces faux site qui circulent il
faut savoir que ce sont encore une
infraction criminelle d'acheter du
cannabis que l'on sait et de sources
illicites donc évidemment si on se fait
prendre
là on pourra plaider l'ignorance mais il
faut quand même prendre un certain
nombre de précautions
moi je pense ici aux gens autour de la
table qui ont des enfants je les pointe
pas du doigt mais il veut simplement se
sentir visés par ce cette égalisation là
pour de multiples raisons devait des
questions adressées à notre spécialiste
marie-eve sylvette peut être nous menons
joueurs parce que c'était facile à 20 et
imaginez maintenant les enfants ils se
procurent du ta box et même moins de 18
ans aussi puis c'est facile l'alcool
c'est la même chose
alors imaginez avec les la substance
comme une dit madame ça va pas facile
mais ça il va ils vont trouver des
façons de faire
l'annoncé de ce mois ce qui me dérange
dans tout ça je vais vous expliquer
c'est l'odeur j'ai un problème claude
armes saisies ce mécaniques donc c'est
pas psychologique ou psychiatrique mais
c'est mécanique ni l'odeur qui est un
peu plus la commande est qualifié mais
ça ne tombe sur les nerfs comme on dit
au québec s'en tire ça sur la rue dans
les parcs comme le suggère la ville de
montréal
ça me semble être un peu extrême je ne
verrai pas quelqu'un boire une bière sur
la rue ou dans un parc municipal au
québec je pense que c'est contre la loi
alors pourquoi est ce qu on s'enivre est
avec eux une ce gros cigare plein de
marijuana elle a vu à la face de tout le
monde et des enfants surtout web alors
il faut savoir c'est que il ya
énormément de restrictions sur les
endroits publics où on pourra consommer
fumée ou va
côté du cannabis dans les prochaines
semaines des prochaines années en
effectivement il va falloir aussi
surveiller ça de très près puisque la
situation risque de changer par exemple
on parle d'une ville comme montréal
ça risque de changer entre le territoire
de certains arrondissements donc des
jeunes là il va avoir beaucoup de
confusion sur les frontières
géographiques de de six arrondissements
là mais je peux vous dire que
présentement ce que la loi provinciale
au québec prévoit c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup d'endroits notamment les écoles
les garderies les centres de la petite
enfance justement bon tout en droit
public qui éclot également les entrées
d'édifices publics donc une zone de 9 m
à respecter il ya aussi des rayons dans
certains cas de 20 mètres qui entoure
les terrains de jeu qui entoure les
endroits où les enfants peuvent peuvent
se trouvait donc aussi un grand nombre
de protections je pense qu'ils ont été
mises en place pour s'assurer justement
de minimiser l'impact de l'eau d'heure
puis de l'intoxication
peut-être secondaire là donc ça je peux
vous dire qu'il ya autant de
restrictions du moins au niveau de la
cigarette on sait qu'il ya déjà beaucoup
de restrictions au niveau des endroits
où on peut fumer la cigarette donc ça
s'applique également pour le canada je
pense au tourisme aux touristes qui
arrivent ici ces restrictions
pas évident de connaître tous les
règlements et les détails de ce
règlement tout à fait et le dur en c1
tous les touristes sur en scène queer
oui je pense que les touristes quand ils
vont à amsterdam se renseigne avant tout
il freine le temps d'aller sur le site
voir quelles sont les lois de ce pays là
que prévoient les marchés ça va
peut-être même attiré beaucoup de
touristes
et du tourisme qui va sur en est à faire
pour bientôt mais moi j'ai une
inquiétude par rapport aux postiers qui
devrait contrôler la pièce d'identité
avant de procéder à la livraison est ce
que au niveau de la loi il n'y aurait
pas une certaine faille est ce qu'il
n'ya pas besoin d'une formation
supplémentaire pour ces postiers ne sont
pas des policiers cd simple agent pose
de la poste qui vont livrer un colis
quelque part est-ce qu'il n'a pas un
besoin de formation supplémentaire pour
ces personnes-là web est certainement il
va voir il ya beaucoup de points
d'interrogations à la suite de la
légalisation partielle du cannabis là il
ya beaucoup de choses des gens se posent
des questions également sur la
provenance du cannabis qui serait vendu
dans les succursales même autorisé comme
on va on veut pouvoir s'assurer que le
cannabis est bel et bien de sources
contrôlé alors ça va dépendre évidemment
du niveau d'inspection également pris
des mesures que le gouvernement va être
reprise à mettre en place le pour
s'assurer de la qualité et le site qui
sont des ventes du cannabis au ottawa
par exemple sont géolocalisés c'est à
dire qu'il ment je peux pas acheter du
cannabis italienne ici au québec ça
c'est une bonne question
effectivement devait c'est à dire que
c'est pateras dresse de livraisons et
par exemple en ontario vous devez en
acheter dans les succursales de
l'ontario donc donc la même chose
la même chose si vous êtes au québec
mais si on travaille au québec on peut
pas aussi en profiter moi je peux aller
laisse saq par exemple un match haché
d'alcool pourquoi je ne pourrais pas
acheter un petit joint le rapidement le
rapidement fait c'est permis ce permis
est allé vous approvisionner dans les
succursales autorisé pourvu que ce soit
effectivement des discus à l'autoriser
en fête l'alcool il ya une instruction
je peux pour les
à notre lieu de ces - cercles au québec
je ne peux pas aller à l'intérieur plus
prendre je parvins bouteille de vin mais
il n'y a pas d'interdît complet là il ya
quand même une certaine circulation qui
est permis et puis la ligue je voulais
savoir quelque chose au niveau de la
légalisation est ce que ça donne un coup
dur au marché noir quand même on
s'entend pour dire que ça va ça va pas
le faire disparaître mais ça va quand
même donné un gros coup dur non alors
qu'à l'heure actuelle vous en parlais au
début de l'émission un problème d'accès
alors il ya beaucoup de demandes
est-ce que l'offre suffit à la demande
donc il ya ça il y aussi la facilité
donc que c'est peut-être encore plus
facile présentement le peut-être que les
choses vont changer lorsque par exemple
en ontario les premières boutiques vont
ouvrir en avril 2010 nerfs on parle
d'ouvrir jusqu'à mills kursaal en
ontario donc lorsque ses succursales
seront effectivement disponibles et que
les rails ça va dépendre des
municipalités municipales qui auront
aussi un droit de retrait et pourront
choisir sur leur territoire de ne pas en
vue donc il ya une question de
l'accessibilité géographique là est ce
que ce sera plus facile d'en acheter
dans les succursales de l'état ou pas
est-ce que des possibilités de sous
traitance parce que le jeu voyait
quelques pourcents du québec une seule
succursale à drummondville mais ces
grandes leçons du québec ça 5 lui-même
l'estrie alors est ce que quelqu'un peut
dire moi je vois acheté cette quantité
là je vais aller en vendent
je sais pas - sherbrooke est ce que je
pense qu'une bonne idée ouais ben
effectivement puis on peut même penser
le savez des fois on organise des fêtes
on va acheter de l'alcool pour le palais
on peut peut-être leur en vendre où on
leur en donne
il faut savoir qu'il ya dans le code
criminel toujours des restrictions sur
la vente et on pourra pas acheter
pauvres
nos collègues et laurent vente parce que
nous nous ne sommes pas des détaillants
autorisés par la loi
donc chacun devra acheter son propre
cannabis et des restrictions à ce qu'on
pourra donner distribuer la nouvelle loi
parle de distribution donc on peut pas
de plus et plus de 30 g entre adultes et
on a
un parent qui voudraient bon qui
constate le fait que son jeune désir
essayé le cannabis et qui est plus
disons qu'ils voudraient avoir un
cannabis de qualité à offrir ne pourrait
pas acheter au nom du jeune et lui
distribuer soucier ce serait une
infraction criminelle
moi j'aurai une question concernant les
produits de consommation à base de
cannabis
on sait que pour le moment la loi 55 ne
prévoit rien aucune disposition ce qui
concerne ces produits là comment combler
ce vide avec toutes sortes de produits
qui nous proviennent des états unis on a
des brownies sa base de cannabis des
mots fine sa base de cannabis et même
bientôt des bonbons à base de cannabis
comment surtout protéger la jeunesse par
rapport à ça étant donné le vide
juridique que l'on a en ce moment c'est
à dire qu'il ya c'est toujours interdite
c'est toujours criminelle de vente des
comestibles la loi sur le cannabis ne le
permet pas encore donc on pense que le
ministère de la justice travaille déjà
sur la légalisation ses produits lush ça
devrait s'en venir d'ailleurs
on sait que les milenio les nouvelles
générations préfèrent de loin consommé
du cannabis quand fumer parce
qu'évidemment il ya des risques pour la
santé sur les poumons donc de fumer ou
de même à poté et donc il y aura aussi
que ça s'en vient mais pour le moment
c'est toujours effectivement qui minent
l2 de se procurer du cannabis mais pour
les jeunes je pense ce qu'il faut voir
c'est qu'à mon sens c'est là une
contradiction donc d'un côté on veut
protéger leur santé en restreignant
l'accès au cannabis mais de l'autre on
les force jusqu'à un certain point à
aller vers le marché noir puisque on
leur permet pas d'en acheter la du de
légaliser l'expérience a démontré que la
criminalisation effet jamais un très bon
moyen pour faire changer les moeurs
je moi je pense je suis parent moi même
deux jeunes puis je suis rassurée par le
fait que la légalisation permet d'en
parler plus ouvertement avec les jeunes
d'avoir beaucoup plus d'informations sur
les produits sont consommés qui vont
nous permettre d'avoir des campagnes
d'information plus plus efficace si vous
allez sur les sites gouvernementaux
présentement il ya énormément
d'informations quand auxquelles on
n'avait jamais eu accès notamment sur
les toxicités puis tout s'appuie sur les
effets on va pouvoir faire des études
aussi scientifique donc il va nous
permettre d'agir en prévention
donc il ya il ya toute une univers de
possibilités qui s'ouvrent lorsque le
cannabis n'est plus criminel chanteuse
je lisais quelque chose cette semaine il
y avait des gens qui est des savants des
scientifiques qu'ils y étaient très
fiers de cette expérience qu'elle ait
mené le canada en fait un bassin de
population énorme sur lequel on peut
mesurer les impacts de cette
consommation à tous les niveaux de la
santé puisque le gie psychiatrique et
que j'étais rush et la seconde à m'en
servir de cobaye à des expériences que
c'est évident mais en même temps et
lorsqu'un produit est destiné à fuser
décriminaliser ben on peut avoir
d'informations qui est plus crédible et
mieux informer les gens de prendre les
meilleures décisions pour eux mêmes les
éducateurs qui vont pouvoir être menées
aussi auprès des jeunes madame s'ils
veulent moi j'habite à la campagne j'ai
beaucoup j'ai beaucoup beaucoup de
terrain est ce que je peux en culture
alors vous avez le droit et qu'il tombe
seulement 4 klein à l'intérieur si vous
êtes plusieurs dans votre demeure
mais pas que chacun quatre lancers
quatre plaintes s'accumulent pas que ce
soit à l'intérieur tu peux faire deux
trois maisons a grimpé au caire
une centaine de plants on n'a pas fini
de rire mais c'est sûr là aussi un petit
peu rires de travers à comprendre a dit
que c'est préoccupant parce que c'est
toujours le sourire qu'on se dirige
quand on ne sait pas où on va aboutir
c'est toujours inquiétant
est ce que vous avez en terminant voir
pas se laisser sur une inquiétude mais
sur quelque chose qui pour vous bon
allons-y fonçons on va bien voir
bah écoutez moi ce que je les meilleurs
mes recherches ont démontré que la
criminalisation et la répression et
toute la violence policière qui a
entouré les arrestations de la
criminalisation des drogues a eu des
impacts dévastateurs sur plusieurs
communautés notamment si on pense au
canada sur des communautés racisées sur
les peuples autochtones
donc pour moi la décriminalisation fait
une bonne nouvelle dans ce sens là et on
a vous en parlez débuts l'émission près
de 600 mille canadiens qui ont moins un
casier judiciaire liées au cannabis donc
tout tout pas vers la décriminalisation
permet de mettre en place des mesures de
santé publique qui sont beaucoup plus en
mesure de protéger les droits des
personnes puis la santé des personnes
donc je pense qu'il faut jusqu'à un
certain point la piètre jeu pas non plus
être mal comprise mais je pense qu'il
faut célébrer la fin de la finalisation
du moins d'une partie des actifs ont
commencé à foncer plus de l'éducation
nous avons le pouvoir de l'éducation
donc le tabac aussi les taux de fumeurs
ont diminué au fil des ans avec les
campagnes de sensibilisation avec
certaines interdictions aussi bien
évidemment ça devenait moins facile de
fumer mais
avec la pression sociale donc je pense
que c'est il faut investir beaucoup la
très bien marie ève sylvest merci
beaucoup de nous avoir apporté toutes
ces informations vous sentir que même
nous qui baignons dans cette nouvelle
atmosphère depuis quelques jours on
savait qu'on n'avait pas rien des
réponses aux questions que l'on posait
son social de la culture je savais où
s'étire enseignants merci beaucoup
maria professeur titulaire à la section
de droit civil à l'université d'ottawa
bien humble personne avec puis la
peinture que vous voyez à côté une belle
grande peinture en avait deux c'était de
sa mère pour ceux qui veulent acheter
non mais envoyez-nous votre demande moi
je regarde un cadeau on vous met un
petit joint par autre chose qui coûte
pas trop cher la vidéo numéro attend dé
voir comment j'ai appris ça j'ai appelé
ça numéro 3 j'ai beaucoup d'imagination
c'est ça ta juste montrer au canada ils
se parent province
d'accord ça c'est une dit les siennes a
dû présentement qui circulent moi je
pensais que ce serait le moins cher
selon cette liste voilà il ya de
l'estrie qui circulent en ce moment un
autre dixit le moins cher
j'ai signalé d'une province à l'autre a
dit m
comment bien d'en parler c'est en bas
magazine faut faire attention parce
qu'on fait un faux toujours de savoir
que nous on parle avec avec un rire en
coin je conduis pas sérieux dont une
petite fille de cinq ans qui s'est rendu
à l'école le jour même de l'entrée en
vigueur de la légalisation avec cinq
grammes de cannabis dans vos actes oui
vous l'avez normes
avec son incroyable j'ai pas en tant que
tel n'est d'acheter ou ses parents elle
a eu
vous est il que ça s'est retrouvé dans
ce sens elle a pas droit d'acheter en
magasin mène un coût 50 une vidéo numéro
4 voici la petite fille de neuf ans que
la cause de ces bons alors demandé
autour de la table si la connaissent
elles
ça se passe à edmonton dans le stock à
nadia ou à 12 dollars le gramme
voilà alors je sais pas elle établit une
sorte de façon uniforme bleu bah je sais
pas le message derrière c'est une petite
louche tout je pense qu'on pourrait ce
soir web est une guide s'est rendu aux
mains des magasins où on peut acheter du
gouvernement du cannabis et elle a vendu
écoutez j'ai lu les détails ici je
trouve ça surprenant et linate charles
elle a vu une occasion d'affaires et
elle et son père se sont présentés dont
canova cannabis juste au sud de l'avenue
whiteside bunton et son père elle et son
père ou quand même était pas touche à la
mer était elle au courant je ne sais pas
est en fait bien fait
non il ya aussi ont vu une opportunité
d'affaires remettez la vidéo pour qu'on
la voit à nouveau m a l'air trés trés le
sens des affaires elle a vendu au suc
attendait parce qu'on dit que ceux qui
consomment du cannabis ont souvent faim
bien besoin d'une petite collation
rapidement à l'arrêt s'est dit je vais
leur vendre des biscuits pour 2 comme
levée de fonds pour les eagles en moins
de 45 minutes à l'avant du train de
boîtes de biscuits vii est rapportée
je veux pas penser à ça connaître les
effets du cannabis est toujours utile il
ya un magasin pas loin d'ici
un sainte-catherine près pire c'est à 10
minutes de marche même passion course et
a51 donc à la fin d'émission
on y va on achète des marchés alors vint
cerf deux fois le prix on n'a pas le
temps sinon non je m'en veux maintenant
plus chaud ça peut être intéressant
on est prêt pour le deuxième jeu c'est
très sérieux deuxièmement je la grosse
boule c'est bon c'est bon pour 30 points
qui est rapporté leur portée le vous
souvenez encore vous n'êtes pas trop
fumer là c'était lui alors une histoire
un peu bas c'est une histoire folle
histoire parce que nous c'est nous
prendre perspective historique on
comprend mieux les choses revient le
cannabis oui oui absolument
le canada avait été l'un des premiers
pays occidentaux à imposer la
prohibition de l'opium autour du gros
beaucoup d paca et on pouvait donc se
rendre comme aujourd'hui acheter de
l'opium sans problème policiers vous
laisser filer peut faire la même chose
avec le cannabis au canada
en quelle année est ce que on a adopté
une loi qui interdisait la consommation
de ces drogues aussi la cocaïne quelle
année le canada sous des pressions
apparemment des états unis ont dit ok
d'accord on touche plus à ça en quelle
année
ça fait environ 100 ans de mon point de
vue elle connaît tous assez la reine non
non non non la couronne voyez là quoi
mais de mon point de vue oui à peu près
sont en présentant lé dans l'abandon
secteur donc ça ça en 1918 c'est sa
réponse qui dit mieux moi je dirais 1879
1879 y à peu près 100 ans présente 95 à
100 ans je peux pas m'empêcher de rire
pourquoi ça
[Rires]
allez-y 1780 82 kg 95 cents ans
dakar près alors écoutez c'est en 1923
avant ça c'était presse était permis non
mais alors oui j'ai dit entre 95 et 100
ans
voilà c'est donc la reine des bonnes
réponses 1940 hockey dans 20 ans tu
auras tes 20 montées aussi vous mettez
ça dans la boîte à remonter le temps la
question doit être sûr qu'on se reprend
et gagne deux sections sur le site web
qui accompagne cette émission la
diffusion sur youtube on peut revoir en
rediffusion qui s'appelle nous sujet
sortent un peu de travers je pense que
j'en avais trop consommer mais voici
quelques sujets qu'on a traitées vous
pouvez poursuivre votre réflexion là
dessus il ya le beau sujet préparé par
aller sur la consommation d'aliments
avec du cannabis soyez avec les mauvais
non plus seulement aux fumées mais aussi
à manger
ouais alors cela les galères et les
recettes vous aller vers ça vous avez pu
publier dans certains n'ont failli parce
que l'information ça c'est au complet
pas juste juste en partie ok mais parce
que le spécialiste en parle suffisamment
parce que j'ai intégré une personne qui
me parle des brownies du chocolat
comment ça se fait et comment ça sera
bientôt au canada
donc ça aurait fait redondant que je
revienne là-dessus cette jeune il est
beau jeu allez l'écouter cette entrevue
c'est un opérateur économique qui compte
investir dans cette filière là bientôt
barriques faire des dents les animaux 25
cents ça sent quand on chauffe le
cannabis très fort dans la maison selon
les spécialistes
mais y en a qui équivaut aux états unis
où ça se fait déjà et qui s'en procure
une relation essentielle mais écoutez
vous traversez affronter avec votre mot
finissent au cannabis on n'a pas vous
déranger pour cela on se dit que c'est
un aliment consommables comme n'importe
quels autres animaux étant donné qu'à
l'aise je prendrai pas d'étudiants ici
j'ai lu l'information il ya des
étudiants ici qui consomment déjà ses
produits oui mais les marchés n'ont
aucun apithy gamme office au cannabis
gavrinis aux canaries desire importés
dans notre juste maintenant c'est légal
sinon ça existait maintenant 2 3 en
cause qu on va pouvoir acheter le pack
et des flux de plus de l'image de la
semaine je répond par oui ou par non
seulement vos questions non roulez pas
l'image tout de suite
ok regardé par krul il est maintenant
l'image ça prenait un soubresaut ici
aussi l'image de la semaine vous me
dites c'est quoi exactement qu'est ce
qui se passe exactement cinq premiers
rachats bravo vous avez là ça avec
toutes les caméras des médias qui
étaient présents et on a remarqué que
les journalistes étaient sept
abstentions présenter sa cravate hausse
à ce film se tourne qui sont venus de
partout dans le monde
ces verrous et on l'a dit il y avait des
journalistes du monde
beaucoup de journalistes français
européens anglais qui sont venus voir
comment ça se faisait le premier jour
quand même le deuxième pays au monde
oui le premier c'est le premier du g7 et
du g20 premier du g7 et les femmes et du
g20 c'est vrai moyen états unis qui
arrange me rappelle la chine
le colorado puis la californie au
colorado
je fais une papier ça fait quelques
semaines qui parlait de la passion qui
est mort dans une chaude hausse des
cannabis mais c'est une drogue douce
c'est un trop de travail il yad'autres
effet mis à part son kiki mara là on
parle pas des intoxications il ya une
autre tare ni qu'elle utilise mais que
la recherche sur les effets du cannabis
la plupart de recherches s'affine ce que
le bateau du disque et lundi sont les
premières trois ans et à monte monte
monte mais après il est descendu puis
est revenue à la normale
la consommation informations mais les
chercheurs sont unanimes sur le fait
qu'il faut mener d'autres études
oui je vois se prononcer de manière plus
claire et plus agressive je les ai fait
part d'une adaptation de la santé dont
il y en a pas beaucoup
j'ai parlé à une spécialiste cette
semaine qui lance un appel au
gouvernement trudeau afin qu'il le met
plus d'argent dans la recherche pour
qu'on ait des idées plus précises et
plus nette chez les effets du cannabis
sur 9 centimes évidemment un mois
qu'est ce que c'est stéphane 30 g m
regardons ça sent mauvais depuis le
début de l'émission j'ai demandé un cop
est un technicien qui travaillent de
l'autre côté de la vitre
c'est moi
mais pardon est trop petit c'est
quelqu'un dans la salle
d'ailleurs moi je peux le voir le frère
maxime première expérience est autorisée
on peut maintenant montrer ça à la
télévision c'est pas du canada ont le
droit d'avoir du cannabis sur notre lieu
de travail et ça dépend des politiques
ça j'aime ça mes collègues de la section
est légalisée depuis 5 6 ans a terminé
là dessus non alors ces trois pays
moi j'ai pas consommé depuis trois mois
c'est sûr et certain
je peux répondre oui à cette question là
mais récemment notre agence nationale de
statistiques qui s'appelle quel nom
statistique canada a demandé aux
canadiens de 1000 d'entre eux enfin un
sondage scientifique
vous avez déjà fumé depuis trois mois au
moins une fois les réponses quel
pourcentage des canadiens qui ont dit
oui oui oui oui au moins une fois depuis
les mois d'été 1 c'était juin juillet et
août sur 100 canadien conviens avec vous
ont répondu oui
4 et 4 sur 100 d'accord la tête sur 10 4
sur 10 a fait 40 % des canadiens vous
avez une mauvaise opinion
[Rires]
oui moi je dirais 27 27 ou 27% 27%
je donnerai une réponse sur la base de
la fils que j'ai vus devant différents
magasins
j'irai au tour de 58%
c'étaient tous des étudiants 58 % des
étudiants 50 % des canadiennes et
canadiens
j'hérite exact mais moi c'est sur la
base de ce que j'ai vu devant les points
de vente
non c'est l'émission organise au point
de vente c'est 100% de 58 à 60 %
ok on continue on fait puis moi je fais
des trains les trains % 30 % et 30 % des
canadiens vous avez j'ai basé sur pause
et non non moi si je fais le tour mes
amis je pense qu'on n'aurait pas 15%
je vous dirais que même si comme vous
êtes au québec non seulement 10% 10,1
pour cent des québécois en
colombie-britannique en colombie
britannique s'est contre un peu plus
écoutés et j'avais les chiffres là
dessus c'est un petit peu plus oui mais
j'ai pas j'ai pas le détail tenez
regardez voir we are j ça mais mon dieu
poser les bonnes questions bon moment
quand le britannique
c'est parmi les champions de la
consommation et oui un citoyen sur cinq
20%
et le taux atteint 13 8% au nouveau
brunswick donc voisin des du québec
sépaq rochère non plus et 15 pour cent
en ontario
beaucoup plus grave en ontario voilà
quelques détails cité canadienne
voilà on a fait le tour on a fait
comprendre un peu plus ce qui se passe
au canada en ce moment c'est un jour
historique mais je le jeu toujours part
de jacky qu'un simple qui est conduit
axa sa les effets mais en plus c'est que
je connais le moi j'ai jamais essayé
deux fois dans ma vie un à l'argentine
us a terminé à complètement vomissez pop
c'est parce c'est pas passé bien alors
je sais que je laisse un des lois puisse
jamais enlevé par l'autre côté parce que
je n'ai pu se les procurent aux marchés
non c'est parce qu'on achète un général
c'est ce que je dis en magasin on va
savoir maintenant qu'il est qu'elles
sont relax en lesquels sont stimulants
donc vraiment toute une panoplie des
discussions et je me suis ce que j'ai
entendu dire que les langes avec
d'autres substances il ajoute des
produits chimiques pour contrôler la
croissance et site chimique et puis on
fume ça c'est fait pour pour augmenter
le poids donc compris l on ajoute plus
de produits chimiques que de cannabis c
'est le marché noir c'est le risque du
marché noir alors que quand on est dans
un dans une légalisation
on est dans une transparence au moins ça
ce qu'on consomme tu as fais ok pied en
plus la mélangent avec l'alcool par
exemple c'est vraiment la folie le
mélange avec d'autres drogues
ça peut faire aimer la légalisation ne
permettent pas de conduire en auto non
non
nous c'est la la ça toujours interdite
permet de permis de conduire une auto en
ayant un peu moins peur mais est ce cas
parce que c'est comme l'alcool
tu peux avoir un certain une certaine ça
fait oui mais ça va pas être cesser
d'autres cd nanogrammes et quelques
recettes quand même pas le cannabis à al
terme mais il va y avoir un c'est comme
l'alcool y en a qui sont sous plus avant
que c'est donc effectivement c'est grave
quand vous avez jamais flux de votre vie
ça mais il ya tout un autre défi en ce
qui concerne la formation des policiers
qui doivent traquer celle des personnes
qui conduisent avec les facultés
affaiblies par le cannabis si vous
permettez on va revenir sur cette
question là ça se jette une expérience
qu un bilan d'ici six mois pour voir
qu'est ce qui s'est passé autour
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a par écrit le
ministre justin trudeau c'est une loi
qui restent à bonifier parce que
jusque-là on sait pas de quoi demain
sera pour aller vite et donc une
prochaine fois vous remercie beaucoup
pour votre servi aujourd'hui sur un
sujet qui mérite d'être éclairée par
plusieurs faisceaux à la fois dans
plusieurs directions parce que c'est
très complexe merci beaucoup à ismaël
bonjour à part été à vendredi prochain
jeu
oui oui bien sûr c'est déjà vous êtes
déjà au programme
j'espère aller ce merci beaucoup plus
rien stéphane lamart ils ont toutes un
message
c'est en 20 30 avant d'aller au coin de
la rue